they've started the Coalition Freedom
School of Palestine Ron you're going to
love this one uh because I know you're a
man of higher education at the
University of Pennsylvania they have
started a coalition uh Freedom School uh
to defend freedom of speech as it
relates to Palestine or something like
that good luck trying to make sense of
this and back here at home a group of
upen students faculty and staff
occupying a building on campus for a pro
Palestine demonstration they're calling
for peace and Palestinians rights be
protected our Greg Payne
reports this afternoon up Pen's campus
was business as usual except for the
Houston Hall Student Center we are here
to be in touch with reality the reality
of genocide as students and staff voiced
their support for Palestine it has felt
very scary scary and alone on campus to
even want to be critical of what Israel
is doing it was just last week upen
officials said they were dealing with
anti semetic messages that were video
projected on the walls of several campus
buildings and also emails threatening
violence against Penn's Jewish Community
Miranda scof is a graduate student at
upen and also a member of that Jewish
Community today she was a member of the
pro Palestine demonstration calling for
peace to me my Jewish principles have
always made me want to side with the
oppress want peace and um want to see
the Divine in everyone which
demonstrators say they feel the
university is not allowing them to do
that I have felt like the Administration
has really been trying to Tamp down on
free expression at pen um really making
it clear that they think that certain
things are um forbidden or um
anti-semitic uh when in fact they are
not pen has consistently sidelined
marginalized communities this
undergraduate student wanted to remain
anonymous but says that concerned with
the university is the reason they've
started the Coalition Freedom School of
Palestine we hope this freedom school
will be a platform wherein students
where we can Elevate Palestinian voices
the group is calling on pen to demand a
cease fire protect freedom of speech on
campus and Institute freedom of thought
for Palestine we reached out to pen
about the demonstration and the response
to the group's demands but have not
heard back yet as for the pro
Palestinian group they plan to continue
making their voices heard no matter what
This Is Why We Gather here today is
because we want to wake up or we can
still make a change we want to wake up
while we can still make a difference we
want to wake up while we can still Save
a Life take it away
Ron
look there we are in a an intellectual
regime of utter inanity in our time and
one thing I like about Jeff's
formulation is that it
gives some credit to these
lunatics uh of being premised on the
idea that they are insightful and that
they they they're aware on some level of
the of the emptiness inside of them uh
I'm not so sure that the students at OB
league universities and and all right
let's include pen I it's a member part
it's part of the ivu league but you know
we never really respected it all that
much Princeton um
but in all
seriousness I think there is an
expectation among this particular cadra
the Ivy League schools and and MIT and
you know the other Stanford and the like
Chicago these Elite schools the these
students I think
actually do have an empty core but they
don't feel that I don't believe that
they feel that frustration that
innumerable other college students who
are wasting their time in college and
they're wasting their time every bit as
much from an educational point of view
and from an an
intellectual training point of view
which is at least as important as the
content part or the Mastery part subject
matter
stuff the students in these Elite
institutions have
been conditioned to think of themselves
and and the IV Le schools reinforce this
during the time you're there as the
decision
makers as the people who are entitled to
and will run the
world and they don't like the fact that
the things that they have been taught
shouldn't be happening shouldn't be
allowed to be happening are
happening and yes this does give them a
chance to act out and feel meaning but I
don't think it's because they're angry
for themselves think it's because I I
think that there might be an anger there
but but I think it's because they they
are like children who are are not
getting the you know they they don't
want that TV show to be on they want a
toy that they can't have right in
essence in essence they've been taught
all the wrong things given none of the
right tools now they're seeing reality
and they think they have dominion over
it